this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome to WAV Stanford computer systems
lab volume 12 2013
I'm Andy Freeman the other course
organizer is Dennis Allison we're
approaching the end of the quarter so
please make sure you've done all your
lecture reviews by the end of dead week
it's easier to get them down now than
then as many of you know I'm a huge fan
of sensors I think sensors are really
cool because it's the outside stuff
bringing into the computer that it's a
something too useful to do besides just
drive bits around a display but today's
talk is the other side which is perhaps
more interesting air has often thought
of in terms of so-called intellectual
activities playing chess routing cars
that sort of stuff but the bulk of our
nervous system is dedicated to the
lizard brain and below and what we're
very visual a significant tracked
fraction of what we know comes when it
comes to us via touch and our fastest
reactions are actually in the touch
world not in visual or certainly not an
intellectual one surprising thing about
this though is while touch is completely
hardwired at some level it can deal with
situations that it couldn't possibly
have imagined I mean how could we have
evolved the ability to understand when a
plane is about to stall by feeling
feedback I don't know about you but I'm
you know departed from the birds some
time ago and knowing when my does
something's about to stall through my
hands just seems magic but it's normal
and this information is so important
that we have to provide it to people
today's speaker has had the good sense
to be a mechanical engineer in a
computer world to provide us that sort
of feedback
I'm I'm can I guess as you can see from
my slide you know you mentioned
something that's very near and dear to
my heart which is completely partly off
topic and that is the importance of
sensory capabilities I've built a lot of
robot hands whose job is to pick up
things perhaps stabili pick them up
place them in places and what I realized
we've been neglecting is the sensory
side of that you know I'm jealous of
computer scientists who can buy a camera
and get megapixels per millisecond and
crunch on that information to recognize
objects to recognize motion features
gestures so all kinds of things so
what's the robot hand equivalent of that
and that's something I'm embarking on
which I call the spider hand and it in
that it it's job is to perceive things
by active exploration and I'm happy to
throw whatever since they're just we all
can come up with not just a traditional
force and motion sensors tactiles kind
of heart still is technically hard to
get a fine array and I don't think we
need that in order to do interesting
work in recognizing objects does this
feel the same as that is this one of
those and so there's a whole array of
thing that I'd like to see people doing
in robotic haptics that needs to be
enabled by a right kind of sensory
system such as a hand that whose job is
to investigate the world rather than to
manipulate it primarily just to flip the
game on its head
okay so haptics there are several
different versions of it let me do a
little bit of nomenclature and then I'm
going to show you a little bit of a
history of gadgets that people have
tried to build some of our own work and
then I'll show you some two different
rendering techniques as much as in
graphics you do you do computational
things to figure out how much light to
put in a particular spot too and based
based on a model of how things look and
then based on a rendering technique and
your computational ability you can get
different qualities of visual rendering
so we also do haptic rendering and so
that's where we'll get to and then maybe
a few applications so haptic comes from
the Greek to take or to touch in the
early days it related to psychophysics
the study of human perception and so
haptics in the late 1800s began to
relate to can I perceive the difference
between one texture and another texture
if I touch with two points in my finger
how close can they be until I realize
there think that they're only only
so there's lots of perceptual things
that have gone on in what we would call
human haptics a little bit nomenclature
it's a little bit like acoustics haptics
you can have a haptic interface an
acoustic interface there's some words
that don't like to have to size
something that I don't like that and the
word haptically bothers me as well
I happened I some of my dear colleagues
call it a haptic I call it a haptic
interface it's it's a device so that
being said this breakdown was maybe
obvious was suggested to me by madam
Srinivasan at MIT who was one of my
partners for 10 years when I was there
so human haptics is what I just
mentioned study of human perceptual
capabilities and how we do it how do we
move and what do we feel machine haptics
which has the tendency to do more with
robot hands and arms and that's
something I've worked on for quite a
while still do developing hands that can
perceive material hold it stable
perhaps manipulate into a different
position etc and then computer haptics
kind of parallels computer graphics and
that's where you have a model of an
object in a rendering algorithm and a
piece of hardware that lets you through
that rendering algorithm feel some
attributes of that model and then
they're combinations of these if you're
doing tele manipulation where I'm
diffusing a bomb you know a couple
hundred yards away or more closely
Morton and quite commonly now surgery
where the surgeon will have a control
console with some very fancy control
handles and the patient will be not too
far away and they'll be much smaller
instruments going into the patient that
are highly mobile and sometimes more
than more than two there could be three
or four camera plus the third arm so the
doctor can become small kind of like
Fantastic Voyage and can do lots of
precision work they can scale down the
motion so you can you know a heart valve
being replaced looks like a like a
manhole on the screen yet it's small and
inside the heart so there's lots of
interesting things you can do when you
start mapping human manipulation
capability into smaller physical
environments so common to the robot
patellae robotic world and the
computer haptics or simulation simulated
worlds is that the user interface has to
be good just like speakers what what are
the quantities that matter in a speaker
distortion down with dynamic range and
amplitude whatever there are lots of
metrics and there are similar metrics
here again this may be obvious why is it
where does it occur if you think about
how many things you touch during the day
how much information you gather
unconsciously even if you're just kind
of walking around around and you you
touch the chair kind of confirms that
it's there that it's mobile I don't have
to worry about it too much it's not a
piece of concrete the lots of things
that we just touch we're kind of
constantly sucking in information by
physical interactions and it may be not
just with our fingertips but just our
whole body I know that there's something
there I didn't have to look at it to
determine and I know something about its
properties it's not going to roll away
so if I need to lean on it so I'm
discovering lots of things by physically
interacting with objects machine haptics
I'd still say robotic touch capability
is very much in its primitive state um
you know years ago when the Puma robots
20-30 years ago we're trying to put
carburetors in boxes they pretty much
had simple force sensing they'd bump
into something if he if it forces to
large it just shuts down if it drops it
it doesn't may not realize that dropped
it and it certainly doesn't know how to
plan to go and get it so we've got a
long ways to go in sensing the state of
things we manipulate and then certainly
a lot more to do in reacting
autonomously to that one task one of our
robots I want to have to do is have it
intentionally dropped something and then
based on some simple simplistic model of
the physics how far that thing can
bounce start looking for it and and if
it can find it within a predicted circle
then it can go and get it if it doesn't
see it there then it realizes that it
can't get it so it just sort of simple
error recovery based on multiple sensory
inputs I think is one of the next steps
computer haptics again there's most of
what I'm gonna be talking about flight
training flight simulators are used you
know be fly pilot flies hundreds of
hours before they get into carrier you
know a couple hundred people around in a
plane in surgery there's this thing
where they say see one do one you're
you're with your mentor and you've never
you know pulled an app appendix out of a
live person they say okay your turn you
do it
so you or your family become their
training grounds and we'd like to be
able to accomplish that in simulation
medical training for surgery has been a
concept that's been around for a long
time I think we're just now beginning to
be technically able to do it in a way
that will have positive will have real
and positive training transfer design
I'll show you some CAD environments
where you can sculpt the virtual clay
Entertainment could show up in video
games there are lots of different haptic
interfaces and I'm going to show you a
bunch of them some of my own some of
other ones and again what they do they
enable you to interact with a simulated
object a physical object exploits
point-contact that's something we
started when I was at MIT and I'll
explain a little bit more why that's a
wonderful simplification of this this
job you want to have good performance
qualities and I'll be talking about
those as we go along and you can go all
the way from this device where you stick
your finger in a thimble and it has
three motors so you can feel the x y&z
forces so if I touch a wall it fights
back if I scrape along and there's
texture it starts inducing vibrations
that's tell me something about the
texture if there's friction the force
builds up and up and up until it lets me
slip so there all kinds of interesting
low-level things you can simulate as
well as high level this is a preview of
rendering techniques have we been able
to render just using simple potential
functions where forces directed against
the what the negative of the gradient
polyhedral surfaces are interesting
because you can express all kinds of
different shapes and implicit surfaces
are my favorite one because they're
differentiable and they're continuous
and it's a lot easy to tell a lot of
things about it and then volume
representations which we've gotten into
for surgical world where you take a scan
cat scan MRI and voxel eyes you turn
into 3-dimensional pixels and then you
can have interactions with them where
you can actually drill the bone you can
we're beginning to be able to make it
feel like you're actually drilling the
bone by looking at the spectra of
vibrations you get in a real bone
drilling situation and modulate it with
the speed of the drill and there right
now we have fairly simple algorithms for
remove
voxels we oblate them we remove them
when there's a certain amount of force
on them so it's not a perfect cutting
paradigm let's a big question actually
to do successful training how good is
the simulator have to be you may not
have to be you know spot-on with all the
physics of it there may be enough to get
the cognitive and sensory motor skills
transferred without excessive
computation that's a research question
we deal with all the time some
applications this is a virtualized clay
modeling environment digital clay so
this person using this haptic interface
feels the shape of this seat that he or
she is designing and you have still
available all the digital tools you can
zoom in and work on the detail you can
mirror things you can soften them you
can have virtual sandpaper you can have
toothpaste so you can add material as
well as subtracted so it's a really
interesting design environment I'll show
you some pieces of that some versions of
that and as I mentioned they have been
haptic interfaces on surgical
environments this was from computer
motion I don't remember this Lewis
Phillips this is a training environment
this is a mannequin and so this person
is training to do it looks like an
ultrasound procedure which is not too
risky you can you can train for
ultrasound without hurting anybody but
it lets them have show virtualized
patients they may have particular
melodies that you won't run into in your
everyday training this was a fun
something we did at SIGGRAPH quite some
years ago we had a whole room full of
people with haptic interfaces and we
gave them each a virtual blob of clay
and then the instructor told them how to
do things with it and maybe he modified
it put a hole in it and then he handed
out these virtual you know eggs with
holes in them and let people carve their
name in them or do something with it so
it was a nice kind of one-to-many kind
of haptics that could be a direction
this could go in medicine you'd like to
maybe take a virtual eyes you know a
particular case that you don't usually
see and put it out to all the students
and let them do a dissection of it let
them just look at it but then palpate
and feel the difference in feelings
between a an elastic cyst versus a
crunchy one which might be cancerous
and this was done by a probably one of
the guys at Disney who does character
design and normally they work in clay
but here they were able to use a product
from sensible technologies a company
that one of my students started that
lets them work in great detail on
sculpting things it's better at organic
shapes like characters rings shoes and
those those industries have all picked
this up to some degree another character
I think I can escape that so so what are
the ways that we communicate information
haptically well we've got various kinds
of mechanoreceptors little cells that
are under the surface of subcutaneous
under the surface of our skin as an
engineer I like to think of them as one
kind senses DC forces one senses
transient forces and one set of them as
close to the surface and the other set
is deeper into the surface so four kinds
of sensors density is much higher in the
hand much less on the back and other
places that aren't physically
interacting so forced in position we
have receptors also within our bodies to
tell them you know my muscles I can tell
how much force is going on them from
from two different sources if it's a
light force I pick it up with my
mechanoreceptors in my hand if it's a
heavy force I start feeling it in my arm
if if they're really heavy force then I
start bringing in other sensors so we
have a multiplicity of sensors they can
overlap each other and the ranges they
can sense vibration thermal electric we
also have cells dedicated to pain and
I'm not sure what we do with that and
the important thing in haptics is it's
not like vision where you can take a
snapshot and then process the
information which even with vision
there's a certain amount of work you
know we'll move around like this
especially we have one eye to use
parallax or other things besides
virgin's but pretty much it's a one-way
information activity whereas with
haptics you have to do something to get
the sensor to be stimulated and there
are lots of ways to explore you might
simply enclose something and feel where
it touches you you might tap it you
might stroke it you might shake it back
and forth to see if it's got a fluid in
it or a viscous or inviscid fluid so
there's a lot of
Laura torie things that we do in order
to stimulate our sensors and you can
speak about it being sensory dominant
this is my spider hand idea where the
motion is in the service of stimulating
the sensors and exploring the AI part
that I like about that is well I've told
this as a laptop or a suitcase
I feel something there it's consistent
with either what's the next thing I need
to do actively to disambiguate between
the possibilities I could just blindly
slap around but I would probably go and
you know look for the texture of the
leather if I told it was wandering one
of two things so this this platform I'm
hoping to develop I think will give rise
to how do we say guided exploration of
objects as much as people do and motor
dominant is the other side I'm trying to
move something I want to put it over
here so mainly I'm thinking about where
it is and where it's going to go yet
under the surface there's still some
sensory information going on so I don't
drop it and I recognize that it doesn't
have sticky stuff on it or something
that I need to pay attention to so let's
talk for a minute about the device
characteristics in case you're going
through the catalog and you want to buy
one of these things what do you care
about the degrees of freedom which is
the number of joints is it just a
joystick that just goes for an out or
left and right is it a steering wheel
with one degree of freedom is it a a pen
that is connected to a mechanism that
has full six degree of freedom feedback
so there's a number of motions that it
has and within that how many active
motions does it have how many motors
does it have and then how many sensors
does it have you don't necessarily have
to have the same numbers for example I
could have a three degree of freedom
linkage which would provide force
feedback to this pin and then I could
also track the orientation of the pen so
that on the screen I would see my
intention of orientation expressed yet
there's no torque feedback on it one of
the emerging capabilities now and we've
got a pretty good device for doing this
is putting torque feedback on this
handle which its complexity wise as you
that's three more motors which
complexity goes up by n factorial in my
world so I worry about more joints they
better really be worth something if
you're going to add it and it does and I
hopefully I can show you that so force
reflecting or not there may may or may
not be motors in your joystick for your
video game if there are motors they can
and give you certain kind of minimalist
effects there are lots of tracking
devices that you can wear on your hand
and gloves and you can send a dance
around or that connects now that can
follow your emotions there's no force
feedback in those things but it's useful
in some context to be able to attract
the human motion grounding this is an
area of debate should I wear an
exoskeleton that is connected to a
backpack that you know will fight back
on my arm not clear because I feel the
reaction for want to push on the wall I
feel the reaction forces on my back is
that confusing confounding in some way
or is it distributed so widely that I
still feel like I'm hitting a hard wall
be really nice if we could just put
backpacks on and have these virtual
things on them that at the moment what
we typically find is something that sits
on the desk and has a linkage and a
handle of some sort and that's grounded
so that the force if you're trying to
feel a virtual wall the force is really
going through the ground and so it feels
like it's really there rather than kind
of moving around with your body the
sensing quality certainly a resolution
and when I've talked about dynamic range
while bandwidth counts certainly but
when I talk about dynamic range in
another sense I'm talking about force
dynamic range the ratio of the maximum
force to the minimum force and in some
sense that's its ability the I don't
know the number of bits that it can
communicate of information so I got my
early experience in tech when I was a
very little kid yes again fair question
I mean it is extra weight I mean you
could have an umbilical to take care of
the power thing you know I mean a kind
of simulation that the backpack guys
would like to do is a special ops
preparation where you're running around
a building and opening the safe and
squatting and doing this stuff so in
that environment we've got an umbilical
following you probably could do it in
time with batteries it might work again
there's still a question is that
interesting enough to be worth the cost
to do it
there are lots of avenues where we just
don't know if it's gonna bear fruit or
not yeah my earliest exposure to this
field was in visiting the Hanford
nuclear plant my dad was doing something
there and I was in the waiting room
stacking blocks with this this thing on
the on the left here this was purely
mechanical so it's got actually really
great bandwidth you could tap the the
table on the other side over here and
you'd feel to click and it feel firm if
you tapped one of the wooden block you
could actually feel the difference and
that's pretty subtle difference but
because it's a pure mechanical
connection cables and linkages you get
that really high bandwidth as soon as
you put motors wires and the motors on
the other side you start having more
stability problems and it's hard to get
good fidelity stiffness between the two
systems you can do it
and you can add sensors to increase that
in various ways sure I live and breathe
this stuff you mean well you don't get
it so if imagine you've got a radiation
proof window here looking into a hot
cell a lead-lined room and you're trying
to mix up some nasty radioactive stuff
so you have to get your hands in there
some way a glove box won't do it because
radiation will get to you but in this
case you have the ability to get you
remotely put your hands in another in a
very hazardous environment and perform
the work so there's a handle that you
stick your hand in here and then there's
some fingers on this and it's you know
pretty simple looks like pliers and so
it responds to you're moving around play
blocks and that's truly amazing is it's
just pulleys and cables yeah and they
really distrust electronics yeah yeah
that's true I'm kind of known to be
obsessive with pulleys and cables for
certain similar reasons yeah I think
well you know remote Isaac now enabling
our hands to be remotely acting I think
is a big deal I mean it's certainly
interesting but there's a lot of useful
tunis usefulness to it and you can think
about scaling down as we're already
doing in surgery you're also think about
scale
up we need to move big things around how
do you map the dynamics of a cargo
container down to a scale where I can
still use my personal intuition to work
with that good question a lot of value
in it if you could it's pretty quick
there was a scary thing that happened
with the surgeons which was when we were
doing our early human experiments
actually an intuitive surgical we bring
in a surgeon who is very experienced
with open surgery so if something starts
to bleed they can go cauterize it or
clamp it off with the tele robot doing
surgery you're doing it through little
holes minimally invasively and these
guys just start cruising along doing
things without being really careful
about cutting off the the bleeders and
the thing that can happen is you've you
get a readout then the blood fills up
you no longer see what's going on so
you've got to convert to an open
operation so it's so easy
the point is it's so easy for those
experienced folks to think oh great I
can just go on with my normal way but
there are a few other constraints you
have to so it is intuitive is a pretty
good choice of name for it for that
company sir oh yeah yeah although
mechanicals has the highest bandwidth is
we were speaking of the typical surgical
robot but all the ones I know have
electronic connections between the two
sometimes you want to be in a further
away room there are also ways for a
second surgeon to dial in maybe with the
low bandwidth connection so they can at
this point at things that you're doing
so you get this kind of interaction in a
real world but you're bringing in people
from remote places it's kind of a it
it's like some of the online video games
only there's a real target I'm sorry
Oh hazardous yes yeah absolutely like in
the bomb disposal environment you're not
gonna be pulling on cables like a
marionette you're going to be sitting in
a you know a blast-proof vehicle
people's tolerance to complexity amazes
me sometimes the one on the right here
in particular is a hydraulic
again this is the paradigm if we want to
be able to pick up a you know
sledgehammer and smash cinder blocks
that means it's not going to be able to
put a key in a lock because getting good
dynamic range it can't control those
little forces not yet and I think that's
one of the important challenges it's
getting much better dynamic range in
forces as well as other attributes so
this this little boot on the right here
could wield a sledge hammer incredibly
expensive you're probably looking at
quarter to half a million dollars worth
of stuff they're fragile in some sense
if you break it and dangerous the next
picture shows this guy with a helmet on
because if the master spazzes out and
goes for your face you got to be careful
of it so so there's a there's a lot of
concern about this kind of haptic
interface tell the operator interface
where it actually has enough power to
hurt you more complexity this thing on
the right I don't know what they were
thinking but they have a master and a
slave the humans hand is buried in one
of those things and it controls the
robot hand and the upper left of that
picture this is what I built from my
master's degree effectively I was
coached by a couple really wonderful
people at NASA to build a more
generalized interface for their remote
manipulators such as the shuttle
manipulator and although we didn't call
this a haptic interface at the time it
really was I had full six degree of
freedom rotation and translations and
rotations total and it was two handed
which is really a big step up you know
how often do you really do things like
this unless you have two more up much
more often more manipulating things with
two hands might one one might be less
dominant the other one might be doing
the task so this setting it up with
multiple hands was also a nice step and
some of the lessons I learned from a
Tele operator does that Jennifer - in
France who designed some of those early
mechanical devices I showed had to do
with the friction the inertia properties
and other dynamic aspects and I'll show
you some pictures about that for a
minute people have done a lot of things
like hand tracking and I'm gonna flash
through these this one you waved your
hand around and those where your hand is
you wiggle it and it's got sensors in
your hand no force feedback in fact I
tried I had so helmet on one time that
showed a virtual menu up here and the
guy said hit the top menu item swatted
through it I had no idea if it clicked
or not and did I hit the
there was an you know there's no
confirmation of it and people have tried
putting buzzers on the fingers like
Paige pager motors so when I go through
a closes but it's it doesn't work I'm
not used to touching things and having
they'll go does accept cell phones and
that's weird I'm gonna skip some of
these lots of hand tracking they've been
a lot of legal arguments about who
invented which of these things the ones
on the left have paid your motors on all
the fingers on the in hopes that
vibration would give you some sense of
what you're touching the problem with
pages is it's not vector information
when I push on something I get a force
vector and I know which way to go to
unput if you vibrate something when you
push it it does not give me any
information about which way to go unless
I remember which way it was going to
know how to back out I don't know what
the buzzing means and I don't want to
put a higher and higher cognitive load
where people have to kind of remember
what they're doing so they know how to
interpret the sensor it should be true
on the face lots and lots of gadgets has
been a quest for a long time these two
devices attempt to give you force
feedback on your fingers again it to me
it's a case of more complexity than
fidelity I'm not sure anybody really did
anything useful with these devices as
elegant as they might have been games
have forced feedback devices and again
tolerance to complexity I don't know
what this hand does it shakes and heats
your hand and tracks the motion and but
again it's kind of a one-trick pony you
can tell if you're holding a hot thing
or a cold thing it doesn't it's
premature so yeah this is my one of my
mantras so I'll just skip ahead here for
a second let me touch on dynamic range
once again when people so this is a log
plot of the size of objects the size of
motion or the motion Regent domain that
you might need to be working in to
perform this kind of task this task may
be less motion and then on the vertical
axis you've got the the range of forces
necessary to perform the tasks
your forces for doing electronic for
electronic assembly is about a decade
here you don't need to really push
really hard and you don't need to push
really lightly so it's about one you
know one decade here we've got other
tabs mapped out in here this is kind of
approximate from Lynette Jones who's
been a great psycho physicist at MIT but
you can overlay on this the quick
capabilities of the hand which you know
has a much larger dynamic range one two
three three or four decades in terms of
positioning capability large small
really small the same thing with forces
I can feel you know really tiny forces
and I can also tell the difference
between a nate gallon can of water and a
six gallon can of water so I can
perceive information at many different
scales so you've got the hand working in
concert with the arm working in concert
with the body and pretty soon you expand
you know three four or five decades of
sensory capabilities particularly force
is the one that I'm interested in so
that I can feel a subtle subtle thing a
little burr on the edge of a piece of
material but still feel the contour of a
large shape we're good
so going a little bit of history but
it's useful here I did quite a bit of
work with a force sensing fingertip on a
robot I wanted to see what could I do
with the finger that could tap things
and scrape things kind of fundamental
question for me so i built a force
sensing fingertip actually dave brock a
student at the time built it pretty
straightforward design you've got a
structure here with strain gauges in it
that supports a cylinder with a
spherical top on it so it's a convex
surface that and we can measure forces
and pinching on in any direction just
the net six numbers not pressure
distribution as you would with a tactile
display and we could do kind of blind
palpation we take a sphere tap it every
time you tap it you know if there's you
look at the force vector and assuming
the friction is pretty low you can
associate a tangent plane with that
so we tiled this surface just by poking
around at it pretty basic stuff but
proof of concept a little more
interesting is when we started stroking
textured surfaces so
this is the raw magnitude of the force
impinging on the fingertip and you can
see as you're stroking along you're
getting a lot of noise or some kind
there's some information content in here
one of them so then we do a frequency
plot of it spectrogram I guess you can
see there little splashes of vibration
there's some lower frequency stuff
that's going on here this probably 60
Hertz noise in here or someplace but
this is kind of like speech processing
and the the student who did the
processing of this work eventually went
on to found a speech processing company
so the same idea of parsing information
detecting changes and trying to separate
words from sentences etc if there's a
vocabulary to touch that we haven't
fully articulated yet can I tell the
friction in something well actually
quite a bit I can tell this is a case
where I'm moving in this direction and
I'm measuring the ratio of the normal to
the tangential force so that's the
coefficient kind of instantaneous
coefficient of friction and so as I'm
sliding along the finger has not started
slipping yet I'm just kind of stretching
a rubber covering on it and so the force
goes up and up and up and and then it
starts to slip so what we've seen here
is the static coefficient of friction
and now as it start as fully developed
sliding happens then you get the Coulomb
friction the dine at the moving friction
dynamic friction so we've kind of picked
up a couple properties about this
material and again this is stroking so
there's information in those vibrations
sometimes more or less depending on what
material that you're stroking so it
gives you a way to either identify or
select among project with product
objects but maybe it's more general you
know if I want to palpate an object and
get lots of dimensions of information I
can tap it to get the local impedance I
can stroke it I can shake it I can feel
the temperature the heat flow there are
a lot of things that I could do so this
is why I'm moving towards kind of a
generalized perception haptic device so
I just suck up all this data and see if
I can say is this the same as that well
in what ways how close is it how close
is the data coalescing and okay
okay so let's say I want to simulate a
virtual circle and my haptic device has
couple motors in it but some of those
motors have friction in it so might be
easier to to move this direction and
then it would be to move that direction
so if I try to move in this direction
it's going to try to lead me along the
easy direction so it means I've got to
compensate if I want to move in that
direction so I got to kind of push this
way push this way even though I'm moving
this way that's again adding to the
cognitive load where you've got you know
bad things in your steering one you got
to think about how hard to move it to
get it to go where you want ahead of
time so in this particular case this was
in a Tele surgical context the the
doctor could draw a circle like they
want to be doing a pushing a needle a
curved needle through and at the robot
end it would do the wrong thing it would
slip along the easy to move axes and do
something not nearly of the fidelity
that the doctor would want so this is
where the control engineers come in the
mechanical guys stiffen up things the
controls guys do some special dithering
and you eventually get a circle that
makes a circle so there's a this is so
multi-disciplinary it's a it's exciting
not overwhelming so for example if you
have friction I won't bother you with
the details but if you have friction in
this joint and this joint so what we're
looking at is a linkage that's fixed at
the base and it can go like this it can
go like that so if your force is below
some minimum level no matter how what
direction you exert it this thing won't
move so that's a little confusing if
it's but if it's above some level no
matter what direction you push it's
going to move so you got these two kind
of two extremes then in the middle if
the magnitude of your forces you know
larger than the small circle and smaller
than the large circle you don't know if
it's going to move it depends on the
direction so this gets to be really
confounding you find people with this
kind of interface holding their hand
with their other hand and just trying to
force it into the position rather than
smoothly navigating a force dominated
trajectory hysteresis and these come up
in lots of disciplines so I'm sure many
of you are familiar with this but the
idea of you move your master and the
slave only goes when you push hard
enough and then it doesn't come back
until you pull hard enough that's
another bad mechanical properties
and this one I learned from again my
friends number two in France which is
the inertia of the thing you're moving
actually matters and it if any of you've
looked at dynamics the inertia ellipsoid
for this is spherical I've got the same
inertia in all directions so I kind of
you know I want to move diagonally I'm
not subject to any more extreme inertia
than any other direction but when you
have a mechanism the inertia ellipsoid
changes radically like I'm out here okay
it's sort of reasonably like same
inertia in all directions but if I get
out to a more singular configuration now
the nurse are going this way is very
high and the inertia this way is still
relatively low so that non symmetrical
inertia is another kind of you got to
think ahead I want to go this direction
but it has less inertia that way so it's
gonna drift that way so now I have to
compensate by pushing that way to get it
to go that way so these are all things
that disrupt the sense of presence the
facility the ease with which you
navigate in these environments not at
all so so what's the problem you think
you're solving how do you know if you're
touching the paper or if the pencils
broken I mean it your point is
well-taken
I mean vision is used a lot to guide
remote things no no question but there
are lots of cases where you need to know
something about the mechanical
properties of it is it glued down as and
not and then there's a clusion if then
something's behind something you don't
know and the pencil examples kind of
trivial but so no question cameras can
help and in fact for the tele surgery
the doctors rely on very high quality
vision in the case of the at least the
current versions of the tele surgical
robots they don't get much force
feedback so in order to tell if they're
pushing hard on something they look at
the visual dim formation so that's a
case where vision really
come in and compliment what they're
doing they have great mobility and
precision control and they got their own
eyes to close the loop like with the
camera so it goes both ways
sir no we haven't touched anything yet
this is this is an artifact of the
interface it's like if your speaker
emphasized you know you're equalized
we're screwed up and so it emphasizes
the mid-range and attenuated the low
range that would confuse you as to what
you're hearing I'm maybe not a good
analogy but this as you're trying to
move with the free space it doesn't feel
it feel for like free space it's got
some personality that wants to kind of
suck you into other directions than your
intended direction
yeah the linkages whatever the
mechanical parts are even the motors
that create inertia and that helps you
can buy very low inertia actuators you
can actually put a force sensor on the
wrist and compensate for that we can cut
the inertia about in half before
stability gets to be a real pain so that
you could do something yeah you can fix
the bad mechanics to some degree I'm
such a believer in getting the mechanics
of right as bright as you can from the
first place so that you spend your
energy I'm doing interesting things
rather than compensating for the bed
mechanical design yeah yeah I'm sorry if
you're gonna cover hands specifically
you think I know the will of garage and
although it doesn't have four sensors
does have an embedded camera and what
would be the forearm looking at the
manipulator yeah well I won't go deeply
into hands but let me just touch on what
you're talking about
so when we were designing the first
version of that arm or that robot it
didn't have cameras on it and we had the
problem of occlusion you're trying to
grab something but you can't really see
so you know it's pretty easy to stick a
camera down there and I'm no longer a
purist I'm willing to put whatever
sensors or wherever they help
we built a hand for DARPA for bomb
disposal that has a camera right in the
palm and I really lean towards having
them on the fingertips so if I want to
grab something and I want to find a
crater a concavity that just take my
finger and
want to find a good place to land to get
a secured grass having vision on that
dead end might might be quite a help and
it's getting so cheap and as our
accelerometers and other other
technologies so that's some very
specific work yeah go on
interesting questions about what we
think of is with regard to touch as a
sensor I mean we just generally call
touch site has gone to the development
we realized site is retinas with cones
and rods of which cones are the only
things that really distinguish color
taste has you know sweet sour bitter you
know depending on when it was whether
you believe it
boo mommy or you know four or five
senses but yeah the other senses we have
we don't have that kind of
differentiation yeah I mean touch has we
can tell distinguish temperature versus
pressure versus a bunch of other things
but it's still not as well yeah but even
with touch there are at least four
different mechanoreceptors so we're
doing some pre-processing via mechanical
design of the sensors so you got at
least four different streams of
information coming from their
temperatures a fifth one the load on the
the arm as well as the perception of
where you are yeah yeah so there are and
I'm happy to put more in you know
radiation sensors chemical sensors
whatever I can fit in there to let me
explore things and know as much as it's
possible about it all those pieces are
coming so I just want happened delivery
platform for them so we can go on more
about hands along the way if you choose
I know the thing only get two
applications and rendering pretty quick
here but I'm a hardware guy so they're
the these terms impedance and admittance
apply in the mechanical world here so an
impedance device haptic interface would
have motors that have relatively low
friction so when I push the interface
out of the way the motor spins it
doesn't have a lot of friction it
doesn't have a lot of inertia or
reflected inertia due to high gearing in
fact those of you that want to get
maximum power transfer you'd like to
have impedance matching between the mass
of this and the mass of the motor so you
get maximum power delivery that's a
tangent
come back to but the main point is the
impedance haptic interfaces are pretty
simplistic you buy a good motor you have
a low friction transmission to it keep
the inertia down and when you push it it
gets out of the way and doesn't have to
do anything actively let me I'm sorry to
jump around slides here but I wanted to
go back to the first what we call the
phantom haptic interface was at my
suggestion or nudging built by Thomas
Massey who was a undergrad at MIT with
me at the time this illustration shows
him feeling a virtual sphere and he
happened to put a light on it so as he's
moving around on this on the surface of
this virtual sphere we could track the
light and so it kind of makes a cool
picture
Thomas is now now a congressman so he
has moved on in life but one of one of
his three three laws of haptics was that
free space should feel free you move
around and you don't feel like you're in
molasses or worse that constraints
should feel rigid so when you touch a
wall it should feel relatively stiff
what stiff means perceptually is a good
question and is it if it's a big room
what's stiff if it's a tiny little ice
cube that you're working inside or sugar
cube would have stiff mean there that's
perceptually about I don't have an
answer to that yet and solid objects
should persist at some point the motors
are going to saturate so you're pushing
into wall it pushes back over and harder
harder
and then suddenly the motor saturates it
doesn't feel like a wall anymore and the
illusion just goes away
dynamic range I've mentioned this quite
a number of times well the bottom line
is your power source your motor you've
got a series of things you've got the
motor
you've got the electronic power coming
in which is pretty easy to get good
resolution in that the motors gonna have
imposed some friction on this whole
system the brushes on the shaft are
gonna induce friction bearings and then
there's a transmission and everything
else downstream a good human dynamic
range is on the order of you know four
maybe even five decades so so we've got
an incredible span of ability to sense
forces which just makes it possible for
us to thread needles do ear surgery and
you know take cinder blocks a good motor
$400 motor from Maxon maybe has about an
eighty one eighty to one range between
the steady-state torque and the friction
torque it's pretty good number the
problem is when you start running it
through mechanisms the friction starts
getting bad a cheap motor from Mapuche
they make it more than a billion of
these a year they cost 99 cents has a
lot of frictions job is not to be a
haptic interface its job is to move I
don't know like film through a camera in
the old days the Falcon is a $250 haptic
interface that one of our students here
developed into a company it still got
pretty pretty poor dynamic range but
it's aimed at the game market so if
you're whacking the opponent you don't
need a lot of difference in one way or
another left to basically feel like you
hit the guy but I'd like to get this you
know I'm gonna have to get interface up
to a thousand to one a decade
improvement over what you could do now
would be really nice not sure how to get
there but there are some ways forgive me
okay so the opposite of the impedance
system which is naturally back drivable
is the admittance system so in this case
you have a motor with probably a big
gear head on it and if you try to push
it it doesn't go because you can't
overcome the inertia and the reflected
friction from that so it's like a stiff
positioning device very much like our
standard industrial robots typically so
to make that work as a haptic interface
you've got to put a force sensor out
here you push on it and it knows how to
get out of the way and if you've got a
really good control circuit that can be
fairly decent free space is never gonna
feel perfectly free or as free as the
impedance device however hard surfaces
can be incredibly hard because you can
crank up the force or lock the motor
down so it's as stiff as the mechanism
at that point the the more common of
these much more common is the Phantom
style or the Delta style from forced to
mention the system sensible technologies
and both of these have motors that the
motors are fairly large low low gear
reduction or low cable reduction for
smoothness but they're easy to move
around so you get that free space effect
the one on the lower right is an
admittance device from the Moog
corporation whose has a long history of
controlling hydraulics and very stiff
very fast moving things so they put a
force sensor out here and they have
motors of various sorts electric motors
but highly geared with very smooth ball
screws and nice tight gears and they've
done dental simulations with that where
you can feel as you're you're cutting a
tooth or a hard bone hard tissue
it really feels firm and it vibrates
with good frequency but that's a very
expensive way to go and my sense is in
the long run this kind of device is
going to probably be the bulk of what
people use I'm going to skip the mouth
here
I did mention maximum power transfer and
I again because I know some of you are
double A's the same thing applies in
mechanic's if you can match the
impedance of your motor to the impedance
of your load that you're moving with the
right choice of gear ratio right choice
transformer in electronic contents then
the power that goes in is you're getting
the maximum amount of power transferred
to your load what does that mean in this
will it means will maximum acceleration
out here so it's going to improve my
bandwidth and getting you know as much
bang for the buck out of the motors as
you can so transparency again all the
things I've been talking about lead to
the support the issue of transparency I
don't want it to be there I'd like the
wall to feel like a wall and not feel
like there's a linkage that I'm dragging
around and so all the mechanical and
other attributes that I've mentioned
lead towards that so now I'm going to
shift to kinematics a little bit this is
really more what my background in it was
in as well as mechanical design and this
is a set of peg and hole tasks that kind
of illustrate degrees of complexity you
might run into in a haptic interface and
although we can talk about degrees of
freedom you know this this thing has six
degrees of freedom I can rotate and
translate however if it's constrained
let's say it hits a plate now now it's
I've reduced the freedoms you know X&Y I
can't move in Z I can let's like
disconnect so now we only have three
degrees of freedom and these constraints
can get greater and greater as you have
more physical engagement so if I'm going
to simulate that process how many motors
do I need to do that and when does it
matter my if I'm Mowgli beating a drum
then it's an infinitely large drum I
only need one degree of freedom
so one motor and we're good to go but
let's say I want to play a xylophone
virtual xylophone well now I have to
position not only vertically but I got
to get the X Y Direction correct so that
I hit the right note and you can go up
into more and more complexity putting a
sphere into a hole I got to get XYZ
positions right it doesn't matter with
the orientation so we can do all of
these with no more than three motors and
I can feel what's going on to the extent
I need to
and one of the insights in developing
the hand they phantom haptic interface
which I've alluded to the Thomas Built
is its point it's interaction paradigm
is that of a point it assumes that
you're probing the world with the point
and you might try this experiment at
some time just close your eyes and go
around and see what you can tell about
the world by touching where the point
it's a lot of stuff you can do with that
it's a little bit like ray tracing and
graphic so it takes a while to figure
out what's there that's why we need more
fingers or more hands but it's
mechanically correct if you're modeling
if you've got a handle and three motors
to control the tip of the motor that's
just like having three motors connected
to the tip of my my probe and so it's
it's it's great because it's simple you
can get hide down with you can set it on
your desktop and it's not going to rip
your arm off so that's why we've been
having a lot of fun with the Phantom
style hazard interface now if you want
to start simulating and again these are
abstractions but let's say you want to
simulate a peg in a hole but now you've
got some restrictions on it or more
restrictions or a square peg in a square
hole in order to simulate those actions
you need more and more motors so you can
feel that you're jamming it in and and
feel the force is necessary to unjam as
you're putting the peg in the hole and
many variations so this is sort of the
pure kin imitations view of the world we
have doctors who do mastoidectomy z--
we've been developing the simulator for
them to train people how to drill a hole
behind the ear here and get into the
middle ear so they can do surgery on the
little bones the state pays the ossicles
and so typically this is a fellow's name
doctor Blevins is a fabulous otologist
so he'll make this hole through the side
here and then he's not gonna just touch
with the tip of his tool he may be
bracing
on the edge here and using that to kind
of scale down his motions as he changes
the brace changes the bracing around the
cameras too high I should lower down so
that's a six degree of freedom
interaction thank you other cases might
be if I'm wedging between I'm in a hole
and I'm wedging like this if I only have
the point force feedback it's just gonna
it's gonna simulate whatever the point
is doing but I'm going to sweep through
the bone here so that's that's a bad
thing to be doing when you're training
somebody if the doctor thinks oh I can
just maneuver the
around I have to worry about bumping
into the blood vessels that are on the
edge here all that so that's a case
where you'd want more more degrees of
freedom so you could simulate the actual
contact if you're doing non-medical
things there are lots of cases if you're
screwing something together more than
that and there's some psychophysical
testing yet to be done it is six more
channels of information and so in a
context where you need more information
whether it's the medical things I've
been describing or or doing virtual
assembly in a CAD system or just wanting
trying to perceive the fit between a
teapot and a lid that you've virtualized
you need these more degrees of freedom
and so it's only in the last year that
we've been able to render these more
complicated contact situations and we
have six degree freedom force feedback
devices and it's it's good it's really
exciting let's talk about rendering I'm
gonna give you maybe two or three simple
cases but the obvious one would be if
I'm moving my probe book I'm over here
with my real physical haptic interface
but on the screen I've got a
representation of my point and if I push
it past the boundary I can detect that
boundary crossing and then I can start
accumulating force by saying well
there's a virtual spring and it pushes
me out and that works pretty well
collision detection is trivial point on
one side of the plane or the other and
by varying the spring stiffness you can
make it feel squishy or you can make it
feel hard you can add viscosity and so
if there's like molasses on a trampoline
so this is a cylinder infinite cylinder
coming out of the screen so how shall I
render this thing I guess I can look at
the penetration distance into it or as I
just showed or better you can develop a
potential field look at the gradient of
it and use that to dictate what the
force should be there's a problem with
that though let's see it's not okay look
when we back up with this sphere so it's
well-defined as I'm pushing in that the
force should increase this way but when
I get to the center which way should I
push it doesn't know which way I came in
so it's gonna pop me out the other side
that's great feels very unrealistic so
there's no sense of state or no memory
here of where I came from
when I'm pushing on this table there's
no question what direction I came from
because it's not gonna let me go through
it so in the haptic rendering world we
need to keep track of where we first
touched it so we know where to come back
to is we're pulling out you could also
use this potential field approach for
simulating a cube and this is in the
sequence that we started playing with
these things so you could have a field
here that pushes you out other one here
that pushes you out that way and that
works pretty well as long as you don't
go outside of your triangular region but
if you push down here and then subdue
you you catch the forces pushing you out
again it feels straight you push you in
and becomes alive and pushes you out and
then pops out well it's simple it makes
corners feel really sharp further than
that I don't know you know when I first
showed this stuff to of some
mathematicians one of the guys said can
you like render a Klein bottle with this
we haven't done it yet but it seems I
think you have to have surfaces that are
one-way if one of you guys wants to help
me with that if you can't look glad to
do that
seriously okay yeah he's giving me three
that's great
all right so we said well can we can we
render polyhedral models because those
are quite expressive you can find them
everywhere you can make them you can
triangle eyes an arbitrary shape almost
so we begin introducing the idea of what
we call the God object or there's a
proxy they're a bunch of names for this
but it basically it's the thing that
tracks where you hit the surface so it's
it's sort of analogous if I'm I've got
two things I've got the haptic device
which is trying to tell me where it
wants to go and then we've got the
avatar who would notices that I've that
I've hit the wall and it's not going to
let the avatar go through the wall so
I'm pulling along I can't have enough
hands hit the wall and you stretch the
spring so the the haptic device
continues on into the into the volume of
the actual of the virtual thing that
you're trying to feel and now as you
move around the item on the avatar on
the surface can't contract me if there's
friction it won't move if there is no
friction it'll follow me along and I'll
illustrate this in a moment and then as
I even if I pull further further four
further it still knows I came in from
this direction so it's always going to
supply the right restoring force to get
me back out of that volume there are
many tricks that have to come up such as
how do you simulate friction it's quite
doable
goro shading if you have something
that's polyhedral that you want to make
it feel sound or smooth surface you can
you can interpolate the surface normal
so it feels round even though it's flat
so this is just what I Illustrated with
my hands here I'm moving into a surface
check for collision no collision finally
there is collision so I parked my Abitur
on the surface and stretched my haptic
device inwards just as I pilla strated
with the rubber band
now if I slide sideways oops
doesn't really show it if it's a
frictionless surface and I pull into it
and I move friction it's going to follow
up if it's if there's friction on this
wall that I'm running into I'm going to
pull up and it's not going to slide up
and it's not going to slide up until
this force vector is enough to overcome
the friction and call it a friction cone
here so if I'm pulling outside of the
friction cone then it will slide a
little bit and so it'll catch up with me
to the extent friction allows it to
check up you at the camera back there
doing great as I'm flying around thank
you and what's nice about this is it
works with pretty pretty complicated
shapes you know you can have valleys you
can have concavities and so as you
collide with something like this you
slide along and the Avatar slides down
and so now you can perceive that you're
in a corner
because I move back and forth the force
vector does something very consistent
with touching in a corner if I move too
much then it slides up so I know I've
got a surface neck next to a corn
it's a very compelling sensation and one
of the first demos I do with people tell
them to close their eyes we have a
virtual cube out there I say move down
until you touch it no tap it and they
feel that it's hard don't use it smooth
a slide back and forth and they feel
smoothness this is all computational and
motors pushing back then I say go to the
edge and find find the edge and
immediately they find an edge like you
see on the on the screen here because
they can tell it has the right force
properties as they explore it they don't
if they just touch they don't know
what's there but again because it's an
active exploration modality you can
slide around and then you can slide down
in into a corner and know that it's a
corner the only problem is if your with
this is if your triangular as mesh is is
not watertight let's say somebody built
the mesh and it's not watertight and we
discovered one thing that was watertight
when it shouldn't have been some of you
may know of the Utah teapot classic
geometry for showing off different kinds
of rendering techniques so we built one
and start feeling around in it and it
turns out there's no hole where the tea
is supposed to go out so you can't pour
tea out of the Utah teapot unexpected
that kind of fun discovery my favorite
one as I mentioned is implicit surfaces
not sure quite how I got in a murder
with it but this is probably my second
favorite paper than my students and I
have it you can express all kinds of
interesting shapes you can even do a
sort of pseudo constructive solid
geometry with implicit surfaces some
people have gone way beyond this and can
construct quite complicated surfaces I
haven't followed that the nice thing
about an implicit surface again is you
can write equations for it and it's
differentiable so I can tell which where
the gradient is what's also nice it's
like testing whether an inside or
outside of this is non-trivial you put
in your coordinates and if it's above
zero your outside if it's below zero
you're inside or vice versa zero means
you're on it so you don't have to do the
complicated kind of incremental search
that I cross or not that is more typical
of collision detection and these are
many you can find millions of these
kinds of objects on the web interesting
whether they can become practical well
it turns out this algorithm shows up in
some much more sophisticated algorithms
this sort of became the foundation of
how you render
located shapes and how you keep track of
where you touched on the surface is you
essentially have a tangent plane that's
following around where you are and so
it's kind of a local model of your
contacting and you can take that up to
higher dimensions so an ellipse again
this is this shows the if the equation
valuates to less than zero you're inside
and and so on so again we just query the
implicit equation okay so we have to
keep keep track okay so we've gone into
the object and before we realized it was
crossing the the the avatar is following
along but we've got to get this avatar
out to the surface so how do we how do
we get it out there well it's just an
incremental procedure where we follow
the gradient right at at the surface the
gradient is normal to the surface so it
may kind of wander a little bit but it's
if you integrate your way along you'll
eventually find your point on the
surface you have a normal that can be
computed easily and so now you've got a
tangent plane which is a local
representation of where you touch this
thing so you can play some tricks with
the gradient to normalize it so that
your steps
are well behaved let's say and I won't
go through the math and this it's fairly
simple it's an incremental technique and
you just stop moving when your move
determination car tears when your move
is very smaller than Epsilon there are
other ways to terminate the algorithm
but what it establishes for you is the
tangent plane so I I've entered here I
figured out where the tangent plane is
I'm down here now if I move to a new
position inside the object friction
we're talking frictional is still I have
to figure out what the new tangent plane
is and so it's once we've got the
initial one it's easy to drop down and
find the new tangent plane so this this
is a tracking algorithm as I'm moving
around this tangent plane it's following
me around and if I pass outside of the
tangent plane then it says I broke in
contact with it and lots of subtle
questions like how do you know when you
broke contact and I'm not going to go
through that
so again to summarize the implicit
surface rendering detection of contact
is easy you do a little bit of
integration the beginning to find out
where you contact it and then you then
you track the tangent plane as you move
along and that becomes the surface
against which you reference your
stretching of your spring that connects
you to the to the avatar interesting
questions I don't go into this but there
are singularities like the heart that I
showed it has a singularity I guess
because it's quantized it's not perfect
singularity but you would think the
equations would blow up and I really
didn't test this but it turns out when
you get into a little crevice like that
the forces start oscillating back and
forth that a little limit cycle gets
started but on average those forces are
pointing out and it feels like I've
gotten into a crevice and if I move
along I can feel the the distance the
length of it maybe it's curved and so
that was just serendipity I'm rendering
implicit surfaces a little bit of a pain
unless you want to rate trace it what
you tick we can't do not yet in real
time finally I'm gonna I think finally
I'm gonna touch on some of our medical
simulation doctor Blevins in the lower
right is a otologist very skilled very
experienced he's worked with us for
quite a number of years to virtualize
first of all the mastoidectomy process
procedure it's actually hard to find
cadaver bones that are appropriate for
testing this for training this rather
it's a very very delicate procedure
because you've got blood vessels and
you've got nerves facial nerve and a lot
of things that you don't want to mess up
with yet you still have to gain access
to the middle ear so that you can go in
these are the stay peas and the ossicles
the three little bones that connect your
ear drum into your cochlea and people
have all sorts of problems that happen
with these things injury sometimes there
are growths in here benign or otherwise
that destroy these in fact my son had
had a problem with these a benign tumor
in here and so google doctor Blevins
fixed it yet my son now has two titanium
proce theses in his ears and he's
doesn't have to doesn't have to play the
music so loud anymore sort of but the
point
he wanted to train his residence to do
this procedure in a virtualized world
not yet to the point of training people
and letting them work on on live humans
we haven't gone through that level of
clinic of human subject studies but that
that's coming Sunday Cham the upper left
is our wizard software person who has
recently come up with a six degree of
freedom rendering technique so putting
the fighting peg the holes is something
that he's enabled on the upper right is
a sinus simulation we're still working
on the graphics getting more
photorealistic rendering of the weight
tissue those you have you know mucosa
water blood and other things and we'd
like to get the visuals israels as
realistic as possible because the
doctors care a lot about that
and also we want to get the mechanical
properties even if we just had three
things you know rigid as a bone somewhat
compliant because it's cartilage and
then very compliant because it's soft
tissue that would be enough to add a lot
of realism to it so the world of
surgical simulation has evolved from
thinking we're gonna train people that
was 20 years ago
problem with that was a high cost of
capital equipment and a med school can't
really afford to buy a big machine to
train people they those business models
didn't work out as time has gone on
though these devices have gotten cheaper
and I think the good business model is
for patients specific rehearsal just as
insurance will reimburse you for a
diagnostic scan so they know where to go
to fix things if a doctor could rehearse
the procedure given your particular
shape of tumors and nose cavities the
the notion we have is that that will
improve outcomes and because it's
incrementally it's beneficial to an
individual that then that should be
insurance reimbursable so so our hope is
that there is actually a business model
here to improve healthcare on an
incremental basis I mean this kind of
stuff I'm talking about will fit on my
laptop in five years and my haptic
interfaces don't tell anybody they're
gonna fold outta my my laptop so I
consider my desk and practice my surgery
and then do my email and then come back
to practicing with the next patient
question
yeah we use CT and MRI scans depending
on what kind of tissue so in some cases
we don't have one here we merge the two
sorry what kind yeah yeah yeah well
again we use both and sometimes we
register the two together so that if
you're you know need to go through bone
but there's a tumor inside so you can
pick up the different kinds of tissue
segmenting up and segmenting scans is a
real challenge and that that's not our
research domain I'm kind of planning
somebody else is going to take care of
that and there's a lot of work in sort
of automated segmenting of medical scans
so the top row is actual photographs of
a mastoidectomy and then in the bottom
we have our virtualized version of it so
you have some bone chips and you have
the shapes and the sounds are pretty
good but the visual rendering is not
correct so we have quite a ways to go
and getting the tissue to look like
tissue yeah so I alluded to six degree
of freedom rendering so there's a case
you know I mentioned the wedging case or
just perceiving something I mean I could
imagine if I had to 6 degrees of freedom
haptic interfaces and I had a shape on
this virtual virtual shape hang on this
one and a virtual shape hung on this one
I could intersect these two things and
eventually figure out what the shapes of
these objects were because I got enough
information I only had point force
information it would be much more
difficult or impossible to discriminate
between objects so again it's it's more
channels of information so the algorithm
that sonny came up with allows us to I
think we're representing one of the
objects as a point cloud and the other
one is a polyhedral object but he could
detect all the collisions here necessary
to simulate hooking something and
twisting it so you're getting the forces
in all the directions that you would
need to simulate interaction at this
level of complexity on the haptic
interface side well we're moving beyond
these these kind of products which are
out to a six degree of freedom device
this was developed by one of my former
students
Salisbury same last name note no with
relation other than we like to design
things so this has six motors in it and
is able to control the position and
orientation of a an instrument was
designed for simulating cranial
maxillofacial surgery because one of the
surgeons we work with and so these two
together are it feels to me spectacular
force reflecting grip you know we we
don't always poke things we sometimes
pick them up and I think the ability to
to help to explore objects not now with
one point but now with two points where
I can squeeze it feel if it's soft feel
the size of it feel the friction of it I
can get to me an order of magnitude more
information because of the kinds of
exploration I can do with too and if I
can do this with two hands then I think
we're really golden because now we can
take material let's feel it feel the
texture of it and most of what we do is
with two hands and whether it's
sculpting or putting things together or
perceiving things so that's the
direction where we're working hands
getting everything to run fast enough
and get it ergonomically designed so you
can can actually sit down at your desk
and do this kind of work
soft amuse soft tissue simulations not
something that's our strong suit
although we're starting to do it because
we want to give the doctors some realism
in performing the more complete
simulation of different surgeries where
you have to remove the tissue before you
can expose the bone that you need to get
to many many others are working on this
this is a you know for animation in
films that's already done with compute
farms we need to do it in real time and
then finally a spin out that I've got
begun working with is with a
humanitarian group in in India who's
trying to teach the most poor people
simple vocational skills and it turns
out some of the simple things that we do
with motors and physical simulation can
enable us to teach manual skills such as
cutting putting pipes together a few
simple things no cutting sounds like
strange why don't you just buy some
blades and some wood well it turns out
every nickel counts in this environment
and so if we can amortize a device less
complex than this over a hundred
thousand or even ten thousand people
there's a good chance that you could
actually use this to train people get
them a certificate now they make a
dollar a day instead of a nickel so it's
an interesting offshoot we have some
other plans under
helping resuscitation babies for for
chest compression for premature babies
attorney that's a lot of babies died
particularly out in third-world
countries they're not breathing when
they're born and just simple chest
compression as they teach over here in
the Cape Center could make a big
difference so we're looking at making a
$10 thing that you could hook up to a
cell phone and you squeeze it and you
learn the rate and the depth and you
gain some confidence so that if you have
a premature baby that needs it you can
help out whether that's gonna fly or not
I don't know but it's I'm very
interested in taking this high-tech
stuff and it's been add some some
low-tech sort of high high value stuff
why isn't that a scaled-down resusci
annie i I think it is I'm not familiar
with resusci annie it's a completely
plastic thing mmm which is for CPR
training said it blows out if you if
you're to bigger Asst you can do
mechanically pretty well I don't I don't
disagree the the fellow that's driving
this is a doctor Hellenic who runs the
Cape training where they trained medical
personnel to do this kind of CPR stuff
and and they use rubber babies to do it
and so it can be done but the notion is
what we'd like to track their behavior
you could just put sensors in it but you
could have different size of babies
different you know there's some
parameters and in the fact that you can
do it for ten dollars worth of you know
a motor and a battery and a cell phone
that they already have maybe that you
know the rubber babies two dollars so so
yeah it's a question it's an exploration
to see if there's you know value in
tracking their progress but the way it
feels yeah I I have no problem with
doing it the simple way I don't want to
do it the hard way it doesn't make sense
so so I think that covers what I wanted
I I didn't leave much time for questions
but I'm certainly happy to you can see
the things I've said about what what do
I think is next and it's kind of mom and
apple pie but I certainly want more
fingers and more hands I don't think
we're gonna get a Waldo or a holodeck in
any of our lifetimes or grandchildren's
lifetimes could be surprised but I think
this kind of tool tool based interaction
is is really a good way to go on this
it's tractable and it's can be grown to
be higher and higher performing great
fidelity in this
so I'm open for questions or comments
thoughts sir so what fraction of
operations in the hospital so let's see
I'm really talking about two things one
is this simulation for training or
planning but the other one is the
robotic surgery that you're talking
about and the only one that I have good
you know expert or exposure to was the
Intuitive Surgical System and they've
done thousands if not tens of thousands
of procedures they have about two
thousand these machines out in the field
now these are million-dollar robots
you've got a console with the guy sits
out and you've got the robot over here
at the at the operating table and so for
the for the hospital to make good on its
investment they have to do multiple
procedures per day and they are doing
that so my guess is we're looking at
tens of thousands of operations the
company originally thought that heart
surgery cardiac bypass would be the
market because instead of opening up the
person you can do it minimally
invasively
because it would have enough dexterity
didn't turn out to be a good market
because their vessels on the backside of
the heart are the things that are hard
to get to but was turned out to be a
really useful application is radical
prostatectomies but that they can be
done minimally invasively and you know
in that operation you want to be very
careful about not damaging the nerves or
the blood vessels and because of the
precision that you can work with that
robot because it's scaling your motions
down that that's been one of the the big
markets for them there are other ones
they do accomplish a certain that takes
12 hours there was some facial surgery
done recently that required a long time
and the doctor sitting at a very
comfortable place with a very good
quality visual image and so there are
other reasons besides the dexterity that
this turns out then the ability to have
a third arm so instead of having a
resident retracting the doctor can kind
of switch control to this arm then say
hope you know click it in place and then
go back to manipulating the other two so
there's and then there's the fantasy
where I could do surgery on the moon
from here time delay and even though
light goes fast it's the buffering and
the cost of a reliable channel and all
those things you're not going to be
manipulating sharp tools at great
distances because of the I think mainly
the cost and the reliability other
thoughts questions
okay I think we're good I'll hang up for
a little bit afterwards because people
want to chat about a lot of it we're
good for now thank you
you